well in today's society you know I
quoted a bud shoberg line about boxing
is chess played with human bodies we're
in a violent world you've got mixed
martial arts which is Grand Theft Auto
played with human bodies I don't know
whether the cages are there to keep the
participants in of the spectators out I
haven't heard banned
boxing for 20 years as a society gets
more violent yes there was a call for
the AMA I used to argue with them back
in the 80s
they'd say there's brain damage and I
said yeah if you get hit and a head too
many times but so they're in football no
there's not in football and they go on
they're wearing helmets
tell that to the guys who are now like
John Mackey walking into walls all of a
sudden they found it in football Troy
Aikman retired after inked concussions
in boxing you get a knock out if you're
knocked out you're suspended for 30 days
in football if you're lying on the
ground with a concussion they'll take
you out and put you back in in 30
seconds and the announcers trivialize
that he got a dinger he's going to the
wrong sideline looking out the ear hole
he's got a dinger so boxing I think has
really there was a study done where I
think it was a 9th or 10th most
dangerous sport and those above it
including luge and bungee jumping and
now football are accepted and so is
boxing boxing has other problems so it's
lost its place in terms of favoritism
amongst the sports fan and part of that
reason is simply stated that when it was
at the top of the fan preference list
back in the first for the first 50 years
of the last century through 1950s
there were only three sports a major
import that was boxing baseball and
horse-racing pro football didn't come to
the into the popular frame of reference
and into great popularity until 58 - the
New York Giants played the Baltimore
Colts and the greatest game ever played
etc you couldn't give away pro
basketball displayed in the afternoon
they all came of age and boxing kept
going down the list of preferred sports
we now have so many sports I mean did
you know that Texas Hold'em as a sport I
see it on ESPN all the time I'm waiting
for competitive pole dancing I mean it's
gotten silly out there but everything's
a sport X Games Y games e games who
cares games y is right y games but
boxing continues to lose its position
and that's a problem in the heavyweight
champions a day or so almost anonymous
you could put them all in a police
lineup in gloves robes and trunks
holding their belts aloft and not only
would no one know who they are they
wouldn't know what these guys do for a
living but a heavyweight champion was
the great we haven't add a heavyweight
champion and so long that we could
identify with whose name is in Klitschko
and I think there's only one there two
of them keep walking out of a room and
changing their name ID the one guy that
it suffers the sports suffers because
there's not that identify at least in
the United States
I'll tell you what the problem is Lennox
Lewis very good fighter showed us that
fighters 250 pounds or more good move
good punch could be entertaining could
box now Rocky Marciano was 189 Joe Lewis
was 204 this is at their heaviest
Muhammad Ali is 224 it is heaviest we've
now got heavy weights up to 300 pounds
Nikolay Valuev a bad bad bad bad bad a
lot of easy a lot of ease and I'm a kid
a talented kid an American let's just
stay there who is talented in an
athleticism
an athletic away and over 250 pounds
will go into football the best American
heavyweights are named Ray Lewis and
Brian Urlacher because they're over 250
and they can make more money that's what
happened to the heavyweight division in
America